J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour. Aujourd'hui, un épisode assez spécial, si j'ai l'impression que je dis ça à chaque fois.
Aujourd'hui n'est pas une journée ordinaire, le petit lardon. Je reçois une politicienne, Margaux De Ré, qui est députée, qui siège au Parlement bruxellois et au Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Sauf que cette députée, je la connais personnellement. Genre, on a bu du coup ensemble, on est allés ensemble aux Pays-Bas, j'ai bossé avec sa start-up et elle écoute Septante Minutes Avec.
Du coup, et je vois venir les critiques, il ne s'agit pas ici de faire semblant que j'ai une quelconque indépendance ou distance par rapport au sujet.
Vous allez l'entendre, cette interview se concentre sur son parcours, son entrée en politique, parce qu'elle n'était pas du tout députée quand je l'ai connue,
mais aussi sur la misogynie qu'elle doit subir et finalement sur son malaise par rapport au cadre très rigide dans lequel elle doit évoluer,
elle qui vient pas de ce monde-là.
Bref, on parle de Margaux et de ses aventures. On n'a absolument pas parlé de sujets politico-politiques, du style abattage rituel, taxation des surprofits et tout le branle, tout ça.
Ce n'est pas le but et j'ajoute que ce n'est pas le but non plus de lui faire de la publicité à des, à des fins électorales.
Déjà parce qu'elle-même n'est pas sûre de se représenter et ensuite parce que je vous le demande : s'il vous plaît, ne votez pas pour des politiques juste parce qu'ils ou elles ont l'air sympa.
Ne vous laissez pas influencer. Regardez comment ils ou elles votent.
Vous allez voir que j'ai passé un très bon moment avec Margaux, de la même manière que j'ai passé un bon moment il y a deux mois avec Caroline Désir ou autrefois avec Alexandre De Croo.
Bref, ce podcast n'est pas un podcast partisan. J'interviewe des gens de toutes les couleurs politiques. Sur ce, bonne écoute.
Ah oui, dernière précision, je mesure un mètre nonante-quatre. C'est important pour la suite. C'est parti. Donc concrètement, le truc qui, qui est un peu particulier avec ta situation-
Mmm-hmm.
C'est que déjà, on se connaît.
On n'est pas tellement dans la démarche ici d'une, d'une interview politique. On est plus dans le : avant, t'étais pas une politicienne-
Mmm-hmm.
Quand je te connaissais. Et puis tu l'es devenue.
Et puis t'as vu des trucs qui te semblent pas normaux, si je, si je comprends bien. Et t'es là pour un peu vider ton, ton sac et dénoncer.
Est-ce que c'est ça ta démarche ? Quelle est ta démarche, Margaux De Ré ?
Ben en effet, ça va faire deux ans et demi maintenant que je suis dans ce parlement, dans ce joli bureau, dans ces hémicycles qui sont un peu plus loin, etc.
Et c'est vrai que déjà, premièrement, je pense que j'ai énormément changé. Alors changer-
En général ? OK.
Ouais, changer, ça veut tout dire et rien dire, donc on pourra y revenir.
Mais en plus de ça, j'ai observé plein de choses et je crois que aujourd'hui, s'il y a une partie de gens qui se sentent en déconnexion beaucoup avec les représentants et représentantes politiques,
c'est aussi parce que l'institution marche pas toujours super bien.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc le fait d'avoir un regard neuf sur l'institution vieille,
à savoir mon regard neuf, l'institution vieille, c'est le Parlement, pour un peu justement essayer de comprendre en fait, c'est quoi les blocages, qu'est-ce qui est, qu'est-ce qui rend aujourd'hui,
l'identification des gens au monde politique compliquée.
Ben, c'est un truc que je peux en effet expliquer quoi. Avec des trucs scandaleux et puis avec des trucs chouettes aussi.
Parce que je suis quand même optimiste hein, dans la vie.
Ça va, on va essayer de mélanger tout ça, le scandaleux et le chouette. Mais concrètement, cette déconnexion dont tu parles, c'est quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup remarqué.
Je sais pas si tu situes, il y a une émission en France qui s'appelle Backseat avec Léa Chamboncel et Usul et voilà.
J'ai déjà vu des extraits.
C'est ça. Oui, oui, ça circule. Voilà. Et un truc qui est hyper récurrent là-dedans, c'est qu'ils invitent des politiciens et aussi des youtubeurs, twittos, tout ça.
Et à chaque fois que c'est un influenceur qui vient et qu'on lui pose la question de : Quelle est ta position politique ?
Ou des choses comme ça. La réponse qui arrive presque neuf fois sur dix, c'est : Ouf, moi, je me sens pas légitime pour avoir un avis.
C'est très loin de moi, etc. Et je pense que ça vient en partie du fait que les politiciens ont l'air d'évoluer sur un autre plan que nous, la plèbe, les simples gens.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc, je pense qu'une démarche de dire : Eh mais non, mais en fait, moi, je suis députée, mais je suis encore humaine, j'ai des poumons, je respire comme vous, voilà.
Je pense que c'est pas inutile.
Oui. Et je crois que tu as raison et qu'en fait, 'fin, en fait, il faut qualifier les choses, je crois, et que le monde politique, c'est un monde hyper bourgeois, hyper masculin-
D'accord.
Hyper codifié sur ces deux piliers-là.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc en fait, évidemment, si t'es ni bourgeois ni un homme, ben tu as du mal à t'identifier.
Et bourgeois et masculin de par la composition du parlement, des sièges ? Ou bien est-ce que ça va encore plus loin ?
Il y a vraiment des codes inscrits dans le marbre qui sont...
Moi, je crois que c'est un joyeux mélange, si tu veux, où déjà, bon donc là, t'es rentré dans le parlement, mais par le côté bureau.
Donc t'as pas vu le décorum, à l'entrée avec les grands pilastres, les sculptures, les peintures, tout ça.
Ah oui, OK.
Mais déjà ça, tu vois, je veux dire, être habitué à marcher sur des moquettes en velours rouge avec des dorures au mur.
'Fin, personnellement, moi, ça m'est jamais arrivé, à part dans des musées dans ma vie, tu vois.
Tu voudrais un parlement comment ?
Ben je sais pas, mais en tout cas, il y a un poids de l'institution, je pense-
Je comprends.
Qui, qui direct met, enfin, c'est pour ça-
Met une distance avec-
Bien sûr.
Les simples gens, entre guillemets.
Et moi, ça m'arrive souvent de faire venir des gens de l'extérieur au Parlement pour des réunions, etc.
Et toujours, je fais le petit exercice de traverser au moins les salles à l'entrée et la salle du Parlement pour que les gens voient, parce que je trouve ça important.
Et direct, par exemple, quand on arrive dans les espaces, les gens parlent plus bas.
Tu l'as pas fait pour moi.
Ben, on était pressés. Mais directement, les gens parlent beaucoup plus bas, en fait.
Ah oui, OK.
Tu vois, comme s'ils étaient un peu genre : on chuchote parce qu'on est dans un endroit un peu-
Certaine humilité par rapport au-
Voilà.
L'importance, l'institution qui est autour de nous.
Et je crois que moi, cette histoire de, finalement, de décor, elle est aussi directement liée à la perception qu'on a de la population de ce que c'est un parlement quoi.
Mais donc, c'est très naïf et simpliste comme question, mais tu voudrais que le Parlement ait un look différent et soit plus comme les vrais gens ? Tu sais.
Ben, en tout cas, ça pourrait faire partie d'un parlement plus, euh-
Un projet plus global.
Ouvert, voilà, d'avoir des lieux qui sont un peu plus accueillants. Par exemple, croiser des enfants au Parlement, c'est super rare.
C'est bizarre, hein, quand même. On prend des décisions qui concernent quand même-
Mais sur l'école.
Oui, mais tu vois ce que je veux dire. Tu viens pas quand tu-
Oui, le mercredi après-midi, ils sont pas là quoi.
Oui, voilà. Le personnel, c'est jamais arrivé que je croise des gens qui sont avec leurs-- Mais alors que dans plein de métiers du monde, tu croises des enfants dans les couloirs, etc.
Il y a vraiment un truc, ouais, comme une espèce de, 'fin pas une espèce, une sacralisation des lieux quoi. Et je crois que cette sacralisation, elle va aussi avec la fonction et tu vois.
Oui. Et en même temps, si c'était complètement désacralisé, il y aura un problème aussi, non ?
Ben, je pense que ça y gagne. Enfin, ça gagne en tout cas en proximité à le faire. Surtout que ce qu'on remarque, c'est que c'est pas parce qu'un lieu est sacralisé que les gens ont,
confiance dans ce qui s'y dit et dans les décisions qui y sont prises, etc.
Par exemple, hein, mais je trouve que le Parlement européen, qui organise des expos, dans lequel on peut aller très facilement visiter, etc.
A une dimension plus ouverte. Alors eux, ils ont le problème que c'est un niveau de pouvoir qui est tellement haut qu'ils ont intérêt à faire ça.
Sinon, les gens seraient là, genre l'Europe-
L'Europe de manière générale.
Abstraite quoi.
Mais en plus hyper complexe avec dix mille institutions à l'intérieur de l'Europe.
C'est ça. Mais donc, mais au moins, je pense que sur les bâtiments qu'il y a à Schuman, t'as quand même un truc de...
Par exemple, les touristes, ils vont le visiter quoi.
C'est plus récent aussi.
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Mais donc là, je pense qu'en effet, il y a-- après, il y a sacralisation, comment dire, des lieux.
Puis, il y a aussi sacralisation forte de la fonction, je trouve. Et t'as quand même un truc de... 'Fin, par exemple, bon moi, là, tu me vois, je suis en veste en jeans, sans chemise, j'ai pas...
'Fin, voilà, je suis habillée comme ça aussi-
Est-ce que t'as déjà croisé des parlementaires ou du staff qui étaient surpris, choqués par ta tenue ou est-ce que c'est ?
Alors les commentaires sur les tenues, c'est une récurrence, une récurrente en politique. Ça, c'est clair. Mais c'est-
Qu'est-ce que tu as pu entendre, par exemple ? Au sujet de...
T'es bien habillée aujourd'hui.
Ta veste en denim. OK.
D'habitude, c'est mal habillé parce que genre, j'ai foutu un tailleur, tu vois.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est un compliment qui sous-entend qu'en fait, d'habitude t'es un clochard.
Alors que, 'fin, je veux dire, ça va. 'Fin, j'ai pas l'impression d'être-
Tu veux que je te donne mon avis ?
C'est ça. Mais par exemple, c'est rigolo, mais quand je suis entrée au Parlement directement-- donc moi, je suis toujours en baskets.
Là, j'ai mes baskets, je supporte pas marcher avec-
Montre-les à la caméra.
Voilà. C'est beaucoup d'exercice, ce podcast. Mais par exemple, je supporte pas, 'fin, j'ai un peu de mal avec les talons, des trucs comme ça, parce que je trouve ça pas pratique.
Et or, je suis dans mon boulot-
C'est pas ton style, c'est pas ta nature quoi, oui.
Et du coup, la première question que je me suis demandée quand j'ai commencé, genre mon premier jour, c'était à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles et je me suis dit : Waouh !
Est-ce que je dois mettre des talons, des trucs ou je peux y aller en baskets ? Je me souviens, j'ai fait le trajet dans les mystiques, j'ai sondé toutes les chaussures de tout le monde, je regardais, j'étais là : mmh, mmh, mmh.
Puis j'ai vu quelques élus plus jeunes qui étaient aussi en sneakers ou quoi. Et donc j'étais là : en fait, ça va, il y a moyen.
Mais néanmoins, c'est quand même fort codifié, etc.
Codifié que tu ressens à travers les commentaires ou juste à travers les tenues que tu observes autour de toi ?
Plutôt, ouais, ben, les commentaires chez certains et certaines. Je veux dire, les commentaires sur les vêtements, comme je te disais, c'est monnaie courante.
Ça arrive tout le temps quoi d'entendre : Ah, 'fin, je sais pas, moi.
C'est intéressant de voir que-- pardon, je t'ai coupé, mais on parlait du fait que c'était sacralisé, une institution, tout ça.
Donc des dorures très impressionnantes. Par contre, se tenir avec un minimum de respect et de bienséance, ça, apparemment, ça fait pas partie des codes de l'institution.
C'est pour ça que je dis, c'est bourgeois. C'est typique d'une espèce de culture bourgeoise, dans les formes, on est bien, mais derrière, on n'est pas chouette quoi, tu vois.
Mais oui, et j'essaie de revenir avec ça, mais est-ce que bourgeois, ça a aussi une connotation politique ? Il y a par exemple un parti très très anti-bourgeois qui est de plus en plus important en Belgique francophone.
Est-ce que donc ces commentaires que tu qualifies de bourgeois, tu les entends de tous les côtés, de tous les partis ou ça reste un truc plutôt du côté du MR ou qu'est-ce que ?
C'est plus un truc de conservateur d'office, en fait. Et ce côté sacralisation de l'institution, ça l'est fort.
C'est une combinaison des deux, en fait.
Ouais. Et je donne un exemple qui n'est pas le cas d'un député, d'une députée femme et d'un député homme. Mais par exemple, on a un collègue qui vient du monde du spectacle et qui a déjà fait quelques petites vannes en commission
où il amenait un objet un peu rigolo, une camera obscura, des choses comme ça.
Et ça casse fort les codes quoi. Et du coup, il y a après des tweets qui disent : Oh là là, mais tel député, il respecte plus notre institution.
Alors que le fond politique de ce qu'il amenait était hyper intéressant, juste pour accrocher ses collègues. Parce que quand t'es au moins six à prendre la parole vingt minutes d'affilée, c'est chiant comme la mort.
Et du coup, 'fin voilà.
Il y a aussi une dimension maintenant où j'ai l'impression que de plus en plus de députés, en particulier dans certains partis,
savent que c'est filmé et font un peu le show parce que justement, ils sont pas là juste pour les politiciens bourgeois codifiés, très dans l'institution, les dorures, tout ça, mais aussi pour le grand public sur Facebook qui... Donc ouais, OK.
À ce qui paraît, moi, après, j'ai pas vécu la période avant, mais en effet, le fait de diffuser en direct les travaux, c'est un-- Comment dire ?
C'était un objectif démocratique, genre transparence des débats et c'est devenu une composante qui fait que les partis réfléchissent à quelle exploitation ils peuvent faire de ce qui est filmé.
Et c'est clair que ça change vachement la donne. Enfin, voilà. Moi, je crois que c'est un win-win à la fois-- enfin, un win-lose plutôt.
Genre, tu perds un peu en, voilà, en-- parce que les débats se font de plus en plus sur les codes réseaux sociaux, mais d'un côté tu gagnes parce qu'il y a plus de gens qui suivent les débats quoi.
Un autre aspect dans tout ça, c'est le fait que t'es une femme. Je pense un autre. En fait, c'est exactement de ça dont on parle.
Mais concrètement, donc des commentaires sur ta tenue.
Ouais.
Je sais aussi que statistiquement, on va dans le bon sens. Il y a de plus en plus de femmes qui se sentent légitimes à s'engager en politique, plus qu'avant, en tout cas.
Tout est relatif. Ben, je vais te poser une question très simple, très ouverte en fait.
Le fait d'être une femme au sein du Parlement, donc je rappelle que tu es députée au sein du Parlement bruxellois et donc aussi du Parlement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, la lasagne.
Et concrètement, quand tu marches dans les couloirs de cette institution, quand tu présentes un projet de loi ou autre en commission ou devant le Parlement ou autre, le fait d'être une femme, est-ce que c'est un facteur ?
Est-ce que ça pèse sur toi ? Comment est-ce que tu le vis ?
Bon, il y a plusieurs trucs évidemment dans ce que tu dis. La première chose, c'est que moi, dès mon arrivée, je pense que je faisais partie en fait des jeunes femmes qui se sentent pas vraiment représentées en politique.
D'accord.
Et c'est vraiment hyper perturbant de se dire en fait, les femmes ne se sentent pas représentées en politique et en plus de ça, elles veulent pas s'engager parce qu'elles ont peur.
Donc en fait, c'est un effet qui s'autoalimente tout le temps. Donc moi, je pense que je faisais partie clairement de cette catégorie-là.
On se sent surtout représenté par les autres femmes qui veulent pas s'engager du coup.
Ben, c'est un peu le problème quoi. Et moi, j'avais pas trop de modèles. Je suivais pas trop l'actualité politique non plus.
Alors évidemment, chez Écolo, j'en avais développé, mais-
Oui, c'est ça. T'étais community manager chez Écolo avant.
Oui, mais pas longtemps avant. Mais je te parle vraiment longtemps tu vois.
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, donc quand t'étais ado quoi.
Oui, quand j'étais ado, pour moi, la politique, c'était juste des députés corrompus qui venaient dans mon école pour, école de Seraing, Liège, tout ça.
Et donc c'était mon image, c'était vraiment un truc, ouais. Et donc quand je suis arrivée dans le monde politique-
Un truc un peu pourri, ouais.
Voilà. Quand je suis arrivée dans le monde politique pour bosser pour Écolo et puis quelques années après, donc genre trois ans après, dans le Parlement, je me suis tout de suite dit : « Hum, ça va être un carré dans un rond quoi », tu vois.
Il va falloir que soit le rond me laisse passer mes coins de carré ou bien que moi, je m'arrondisse un peu.
Bonne analogie.
Oui.
Non, mais c'est clair.
Cinéma hein. Et du coup, je me suis tout de suite dit que ça risquait d'être compliqué.
Et donc d'abord, comme tu me demandais un peu comment je me sens et comment je me sentais. Ben, déjà toujours un peu, tu vois, un peu raser les murs, etc.
Dire : « Bon, est-ce que j'ai vraiment raison d'être là ? Est-ce que vraiment, je suis à ma place ? Est-ce que je fais bien mon travail ?
» etc. Je sais pas si je t'ai déjà raconté cette anecdote, mais quand on monte à la tribune pour prendre la parole, c'est un truc de fou parce que moi, le micro, il m'arrive là quoi.
Et donc on a l'impression que je suis-- t'as un pupitre qui m'arrive jusque là aux épaules et puis il y a le micro au-dessus.
Donc quand je parle, je suis comme ça.
Mais t'es pas si petite que ça, si ?
Ben non. Ben, je fais un mètre soixante-six quoi. Donc ouais, mais moyenne femme, tu vois. Et donc-
En fait, le truc récurrent avec moi, c'est quand on me donne une taille, je fais : « Ah oui, t'es petit en fait. »
Oui, c'est ça. Mais du coup, ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que déjà, le mobilier, quand tu prends la parole, il est intimidant.
Plutôt adapté aux grands hommes-
Voilà.
Imposants, voilà.
T'es dans un hémicycle où il y a quand même plus de quatre-vingt personnes qui te regardent alors que tu parles. Je sais pas ce que t'as fait dans ta vie, mais je pense que ça t'arrive pas très souvent.
Moi, ça m'arrive pas très souvent non plus.
T'as jamais pitché pour ta start-up devant des assemblées comme ça ?
Ouais, mais pas aussi-
Ils écoutaient pas forcément.
Éloigné de moi. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Ah oui, ok, je vois.
Parce que là, c'est des gens-- enfin, je veux dire, je défends des fois des projets de loi devant le Vlaams Belang quoi. Ils me regardent.
Ah oui, oui. Quand tu dis éloigné, c'est-
Oui.
En termes de profil-
Oui, bien sûr, tu vois.
De situation économique, politique, tout ça.
Voilà. Alors, il y a un truc, c'est qu'aussi donc moi, je suis députée alors qu'Écolo est au pouvoir. Et donc ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire qu'on dit vulgairement que je suis députée de la majorité. Et donc je sais que j'ai des ministres et qui sont estampillés Écolo, qui ont été désignés par Écolo pour siéger, qui font déjà toute une série de choses.
Et donc moi, j'ai toujours considéré mon job comme
aller un peu en complément, si tu veux, des actions des différents gouvernements, parce que je vais pas gérer, je sais pas moi, la propreté à Bruxelles, alors que c'est un ministre Écolo qui le gère.
Je fais autre chose. Et du coup, j'amène souvent des sujets qui sont un peu des sujets qui sont pour moi des angles morts,
qu'on a peu traités dans les parlements jusqu'à présent et que j'essaie d'amener, mais qui du coup me valent parfois un accueil un peu sceptique.
Donc la première fois que tu parles de contraception masculine devant tes quatre-vingt collègues allant de Vlaams Belang jusqu'au PTB, avec des gens de tout âge, de toute origine, c'est pas super easy quoi.
Ok. Et c'est-- soyons concrets. Donc tu arrives devant l'Assemblée avec un projet de loi, par exemple, sur la contraception masculine.
Qu'est-ce que tu ressens ? Qu'est-ce que tu constates ? Qu'est-ce que tu vois concrètement ?
Je constate qu'il y a des collègues qui rigolent parce que le nom du colloque de référence en la matière, c'est Focus sur les couilles.
Alors là, j'entends comme ça derrière, je suis là.
En même temps, c'est un-
Ah, mais c'est pas moi qui ai inventé ce nom hein, c'est un nom d'un colloque, tu vois.
Ah oui, c'est un colloque qui est existant.
Tu vois, je présente mon projet.
Ok, ok, au temps pour moi, d'accord. Le colloque, c'est pas ton-
Non, non, non. Je présente mon projet. À un moment donné, je dis : « Ben oui, parce qu'il y a des conclusions, par exemple concernant la sensibilisation qui ont été tirées lors d'un colloque. » Le colloque qui s'appelle Focus sur les couilles. Puis là, hilarité.
Ok, ok.
J'étais un peu là.
Je comprends mieux, ok. Je pensais que c'était toi qui faisais une vanne. Ok, non, non.
Je fais pas-- on fait pas de vanne dans les
Sauf ton collègue du coup, qui est venu avec-
Ouais, hors micro du coup. Et donc tu vois-- et toujours, t'es un peu pris, un peu prise, enfin, ouais, comme si, ouais, un peu comme un ovni quoi, tu vois.
Et donc souvent, moi, j'ai eu ce sentiment-là de me dire : « Bon, est-ce que je fais bien les choses ? » Parce qu'au final, j'ai l'impression que-
Donc, tu dis ovni. Est-ce que ça va jusqu'à la sensation d'être pas crédible, décrédibilisée-
Oui oui.
De mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette clown qui vient nous parler de focus sur les couilles-
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là ? T'as déjà eu ce sentiment ?
Oui oui, très très souvent et même des fois à me voir contre, à voir ce que j'amenais comme réflexion sur un sujet complètement déconstruit par un collègue
masculin, alors que la personne n'avait aucune connaissance et compétence dans le domaine en question.
Exemple concret, on fait un débat sur la représentation des femmes dans le monde de la culture.
Et donc j'explique que la plupart des budgets de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles qui sont alloués à des projets artistiques sont avant tout, enfin visent avant tout un financement de projets portés par des hommes, donc les grands théâtres, etc.
Et le gars me répond : « Ouais, mais moi quand je, enfin je sais pas, quand je vais au théâtre, etc. Il y a plein de femmes qui travaillent dans la culture. » Je suis là
oui, mais en fait, il y a un concept derrière qui s'appelle le gender blindness, donc j'explique, etc.
Et en fait derrière, il vient non, mais je suis pas d'accord avec vous parce que moi, je vois vraiment beaucoup de femmes qui-- et je me dis mais waouh !
Et donc t'amènes des angles différents et puis en fait, tu dois toujours, je pense deux fois plus les défendre parce que c'est des sujets féministes soi-disant woke machin machin,
de la part de personnes qui n'ont aucune compétence dans le domaine.
Enfin, moi, je vais jamais aller faire la maline.
C'est étrange de contredire des études de gens qui ont travaillé sur le sujet avec de l'anecdotique, du « moi quand j'y suis allé au théâtre, j'ai vu ça ».
Ouais.
Il y a un argument qui pèse plus que l'autre là. Enfin, c'est étrange.
Parce que pour beaucoup aussi, tout ce qui est sociologie, études de sciences humaines, etc. Ce n'est pas de la science quoi.
Et donc quand tu dis-
Quand j'interviewais ton ami George-Louis Bouchez, il me disait que ces secteurs-là étaient complètement envahis par la gauche, etc.
Que c'était très politisé et que c'était donc finalement un ennemi sur le plan intellectuel.
Cela dit, d'après lui, un virologue bien connu aussi. Donc, je veux dire, je pense qu'il y a des gens de gauche et des gens de droite partout, mais bon ouais, mais ça, c'est ouf quoi.
Et donc tu démontres parce qu'il y a eu, je sais pas, une étude au Canada sur les biais de genre dans la santé, une meuf qui a interrogé des centaines de médecins, etc.
On te dit mais non, c'est pas de la science. Mais du coup, qu'est-ce qu'est la science quoi, tu vois ? Et donc ça, c'est vraiment, ouais, c'est vraiment un truc qui revient souvent.
En plus, moi, j'ai travaillé donc sur les questions d'égalité où la compétence et la connaissance sur le sujet n'est pas reconnue parce qu'on estime que c'est juste un délire de néo-féministe woke.
Et sur un deuxième sujet qui est les questions de numérique et d'IT où là, c'était directement mais qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte ?
Enfin, elle en sait rien, etc.
Et en fait, là par contre, j'ai vu une évolution très forte du regard de mes collègues sur ces questions-là,
parce qu'au fur et à mesure des commissions, des moments où on avait de la discussion de fond avec des fois des acteurs et des actrices de terrain,
comme c'est con, mais je jargonne très bien en IT, même si je suis pas IT moi-même, ça va, tu vois.
On peut donc rappeler comment on se connaît, dans quel— voilà. Donc concrètement, tu as cofondé une start-up qui s'appelait Nextride, qui a évolué depuis, dont tu t'es distanciée.
Donc tu ne codes pas toi-même, tu n'es pas une détentrice d'un master en sciences informatiques-
Non.
Mais tu as des connaissances appuyées dans comment ça fonctionne en termes d'infrastructures, en termes de technologies derrière, voilà.
Je précise que donc c'est dans ce cadre-là, puisque j'ai travaillé avec Nextride qui est devenu Nextmove qui est devenu Stumling qui a été racheté et donc qui était proche d'un bus avant.
T'as oublié, ouais, j'allais dire.
Voilà. Et le, concrè-- donc c'est comme ça qu'on se connaît. Et donc t'es en mesure de jargoner parce que tu as ce parcours-là.
Mh.
Et c'est le jargon qui te rend crédible alors ?
Ouais.
C'est con hein ? C'est quand on te voit
discuter avec une meuf qui travaille dans l'IA et que tu lui poses des questions un peu plus, mais qui c'est pas, enfin--
à la limite, je le fais presque juste pour avoir la discussion technique, pour que tout le monde derrière se dise ah oui ok, elle sait, tu vois.
Et donc ça, c'est un truc où là j'ai vu l'évolution du regard quoi, où je me suis dit ah tiens, maintenant alors, je suis la technicienne de service quoi.
Alors que franchement-
On te demande de réparer les imprimantes tout ça.
Ah sûrement un jour ou l'autre. Oui, mais brancher les trucs de projection, ça oui, ça, c'est souvent ça.
Ah oui, d'accord, ok.
Ouais, tu vois. Comme quoi. Mais tout ça pour dire que parfois même dans-
L'envers de la médaille.
Mais parfois même dans la répartition des sujets, des matières, etc. Dans les députés, il y a des biais de genre énormes quoi.
Si tu vas en commission égalité, il y a quinze députés qui siègent, il y a quatorze femmes, un homme. Si tu vas en commission santé, c'est quasiment la même proportion.
Par contre, si tu vas en économie, en affaires générales, là, équipe de bonhommes, là, c'est tout de suite-
Oui, un peu comme les sections d'études à l'université, etc.
C'est ça. Et donc en fait, tu as une répercussion de tous les stéréotypes de la société, selon moi en tout cas, qui sont concentrés dans le parlement et qui vont faire que, par exemple, avoir des mandats spéciaux comme on dit.
Donc c'est par exemple présider un groupe de travail, présider une assemblée, être chef de groupe pour un parti dans un parlement, etc.
Tout ça, c'est des rôles qu'on va davantage donner aux hommes. Et franchement, enfin oui, c'est assez-- sauf voilà commission égalité.
Donc le groupe de travail égalité, ben c'est moi, parce que c'est égalité. Donc forcément, on veut bien une bonne femme à ce moment-là quoi.
Mh. Ok. Concrètement, dans le cadre du parlement, dans ce lieu, on a parlé de la crédibilité que tu pouvais perdre à cause de ça, à cause de ton âge, à cause de ton look.
Ça s'arrête pas là puisque tu as aussi été beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup craché dessus sur les réseaux, y compris par les politiciens comme par exemple George-Louis Bouchez.
Mh.
Est-ce que ça arrive à toutes les femmes ? Est-ce que ça t'arrive à toi plus qu'aux autres ? Pourquoi ?
Purée, tu poses des questions qui mériteraient une thèse. Alors je sais pas si je suis en mesure de me comparer avec d'autres personnes, mais il y a des spécificités, je pense, liées à mon profil.
La première chose, c'est que j'ai toujours beaucoup utilisé les réseaux sociaux.
Ok.
Mais en fait, c'est rigolo parce que du jour au lendemain, je suis devenue mandataire, donc où j'ai été élue en fait, j'ai eu toute une nouvelle foule de personnes qui ont commencé à me suivre.
C'est ça.
Et à me retourner des réflexions assez désagréables sur ma légitimité. Souvent, c'est sur ça qu'on m'attaque. Mais vraiment du jour au lendemain quoi.
Donc je suis passée d'une communauté d'IT nerd, défenseur de l'open data à des espèces de gens hyper énervés contre la politique et surtout contre les wokes féministes quoi.
Et donc ça, je l'ai noté. Et ça, c'est sûr que le fait d'être
exposé médiatiquement ou même juste d'avoir le statut, puisque j'avais même pas encore fait une interview quand ça a commencé,
le fait juste d'avoir une étiquette personnalité publique, directement ça, voilà, ça donne un terreau pour des cyberviolences et en fait
toute une série de violences comme ça subies en ligne.
Ça, c'est la première chose. La deuxième chose, c'est que je crois que les sujets que j'ai amenés au Parlement, ben, m'ont valu de vite être mise dans une case qui est celle de woke féministe, tout ça,
qui, je crois aujourd'hui, n'est pas vraiment un atout quand on utilise les réseaux sociaux.
C'est, ça m'intéresse fort parce qu'à chaque fois que tu dis woke féministe, on sent que c'est les mots que tu places dans la bouche de tes adversaires intellectuels.
On va reprendre ce que tu disais juste avant, mais est-ce que tu es une woke féministe ?
Je sais pas. Est-ce que je suis éveillée ? Est-ce que je défends les droits des femmes ? Oui, 'fin, tu vois, littéralement, oui.
Ok, c'est ça, oui. Non, parce que je remarque dans ta façon de formuler les phrases, c'est toujours : Je suis perçue comme une woke féministe, les gens me catégorisent.
Mais parce que je crois que sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est devenu une insulte quoi. Alors que-
Ça dépend pour qui, mais oui.
Oui, c'est ça. Alors que t'es un peu là... et que si, parce qu'il y a aussi ce truc que ça te classe dans une espèce de case où du coup, t'es une espèce de punching ball pour même les fachos français.
Est-ce que c'est une insulte ? Tu crois que tu commences un peu à te distancier du terme ou parce que t'as pas trop envie que ça te revienne dans la face ?
En vrai, je m'en tape. 'fin...
Non, parce que je remarque que tu te distances du terme, mais peut-être que c'est juste...
Je sais pas. D'un côté, ça change quoi ? Même si je l'assume, ça va pas...
Oui, ok. Bon, c'est pas très important. Mais revenons à ce qu'on disait, donc sur... que t'es perçue comme telle sur les réseaux et que... Et, mais concrètement, tu n'as pas, je pense,
trop changé ta façon d'interagir avec les réseaux sociaux dans ce que tu postes, dans... Si ?
Mmmh.
Ok.
Pardon, ça me dit que...
La rage est ressortie.
Je suis pas sûre de ça. Je...
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que beaucoup de politiciens feraient du très carré, très, très formel, écrit par un community manager, etc.
Et toi, t'es déjà plus dans une démarche où tu peux dire : Ah, je suis tombé sur un article et tu fais une selfie et tu montres le machin. Enfin, voilà.
Ça, ça peut-être...
C'est beaucoup plus organique. C'est, on sent que ça reste toi. Alors que peut-être que pour beaucoup de gens, quand on devient actif en politique, on abandonne ses réseaux et on les... 'fin, sauf si on est président de parti.
Mais on les confie plutôt à quelqu'un dont c'est le métier, tu vois, 'fin.
Ben alors déjà, j'ai pas les ressources humaines pour faire ça.
Oui. Parce que c'était ton métier avant.
Oui voilà. Moi, les personnes avec qui je travaille, c'est du personnel politique qui mettent sur les dossiers, des juristes, etc.
Je pense que communiquer ne doit pas être ma priorité. Je le fais parce que j'aime bien et que je trouve qu'il y a moyen justement de démystifier la politique.
C'est pour ça que j'essaie de le faire un peu en étant moi-même. Après, faut pas non plus idéaliser. Je veux dire,
le nombre de fois où je veux poster un truc et je le fais pas ou je poste un truc et je le supprime juste parce que je sais que ça me met en danger.
Le nombre d'informations que je divulgue pas publiquement. Ça m'est arrivé... Oui. Ça m'est arrivé que des gens de ma famille se fassent... 'fin genre, on capture des contenus qu'ils avaient postés, etc., pour me lâcher moi.
Ok, oui, ça, c'est sombre.
Not sexy, vraiment quoi, tu vois. Et donc,
et donc maintenant, je fais attention. Je tague pas mes collaboratrices
sur mes stories, même si je mets une photo d'elles, parce que je veux pas qu'on remonte jusqu'à elles, parce qu'après, sinon, on va dire : Ah oui, mais la collaboratrice de Margaux De Ré, elle est partie en vacances.
Oui, fine quoi, tu vois. Mais donc d'expérience, je me suis hyper fort remis des règles en tête pour, tu vois, pour cadrer tout ça.
Et c'est super trash parce que de la même manière où je pense que les femmes sont éduquées à, par exemple, pas prendre certaines rues pendant la nuit parce que c'est dangereux, ben en fait, dans l'expression,
la liberté d'expression aussi, en fait, on fait des techniques d'évitement et il y a des équivalents à tout ce que...
'fin, tu vois, prendre la parole. Ou bien alors, ça m'est déjà arrivé aussi de ne pas oser dire moi-même quelque chose et le confier à quelqu'un d'autre, tu vois.
Et dire à un de mes collègues : Vas-y, tweete ça, c'est un bon truc, c'est une bonne punchline, mais juste parce que moi, j'avais pas le courage de gérer le retour.
Ok. Et donc je reviens à l'autre partie de la question qui était : Est-ce que tu as l'impression d'être davantage une cible que, par exemple, les autres députés femmes Écolo ?
Alors moi, j'ai le privilège d'être blanche et donc je me ramasse pas des emoji charter et ce genre de trucs. Donc ça, c'est déjà...
Ça, c'est en termes de type d'insultes que tu recevras.
Ouais, mais du coup, ça décuple hein, parce que quand tu...
Oui, bien sûr, oui.
Ouais, quand tu te chopes les racistes en plus, les racistes s'en prennent pas à moi, sauf s'ils sont en plus misogynes.
Ça se combine souvent, mais c'est pas une exclusive. Mais du coup, ouais, je... en fait...
Oui, t'as... ok, je comprends que t'as pas envie de te placer comme étant la plus...
La master, ouais.
Ou la... parce que du coup, les autres personnes qui s'en prennent aussi plein la gueule vont avoir l'impression que ça minimise leur vécu.
Mais par contre, un truc qui est vrai, c'est que, par exemple, moi, les médias faisaient pas trop attention à moi parce que j'étais une petite jeune qui commençait.
Et du coup, les réseaux sociaux, c'était un peu ma seule manière d'exister quoi, tu vois. Et prendre position sur Twitter sur un sujet d'actu,
c'était la garantie, ben d'avoir ta prise de position qui se retrouve dans un article sur le site de la DH ou quoi.
Et donc c'est clair que c'est un outil de visibilisation qui est important quand t'as pas accès aux médias... Je veux dire, je sais pas moi...
T'es moins invitée en matinale sur La Première...
Ouais, voilà, Jean-Marc Nollet, il a un truc à dire à la presse, il claque des doigts, il se fait inviter ou quasi. Quand t'es une petite jeune qui débute...
'fin, moi, j'ai fait une fois une matinale politique en radio, et donc c'était la seule fois, il y a deux ans et demi.
Mais c'est pas grave, mais voilà.
Ça se comprend.
Et du coup, voilà, c'est ça que je voulais dire. Du coup, ça rend les violences en ligne, je pense, démultipliées, parce que du coup, ça devient le média principal.
Et alors un troisième truc que je pense qui est fondamental : les gens savent que c'est moi qui l'ai dit, tu vois. Et je pense que quand ils adressent un message à Zakia Khattabi ou à Caroline Désir, ils se doutent qu'il y a
une personne qui filtre, etc.
C'est moins fort, tu vois.
Oui, oui, oui, je comprends.
Bon après, c'est peut-être moi qui fais une lecture complètement malsaine des gens, mais...
Non, je pense que ça se tient tout à fait comme raisonnement. Donc quand on parle de personnes qui
t'emmerdent violemment sur les réseaux sociaux, qui vont chercher des gens parmi tes proches, parmi tes collaboratrices, etc.
Une personne en particulier contre qui tu as porté plainte ? Comment ça s'est passé, ça ?
Alors donc, c'était au tout début et donc j'étais pas encore habituée et blindée comme maintenant parce que maintenant, j'essaie un peu de me...
Ok.
Mettre une petite carapace. J'étais à la mer avec une de mes potes et ma maman m'envoie une caricature dégueulasse de moi avec un slogan à caractère sexuel.
Une, deux, trois. Ma maman m'envoie ça alors que je suis en déconnexion avec des potes et j'étais là : Oh waouh ! Donc j'ai commencé à paniquer complètement.
Mais comment, pourquoi elle renvoie ça ta mère ?
Ben parce que c'est une maman et donc elle regarde, elle suit un peu Twitter. Parce qu'en fait quand tu...
Elle a pas reçu ça directement.
Non. En fait quand tu entres en politique et que surtout tu viens pas du monde politique, je crois que les gens autour de toi, ils sont un peu en mode Oh waouh, magie, on va toucher une vraie députée tu vois.
Et donc du coup, ils regardent et ils sont super soutenants. C'est super gai. Enfin, je veux dire, dans mes potes qui sont assistantes sociales, puéricultrices et tout,
elles avaient jamais, et maintenant, elles commencent à comprendre aussi comment ça marche.
Donc ça, c'est cool. Mais ce qui est moins cool aussi, c'est que du coup, la violence à laquelle t'es exposée, ils sont au courant.
Et ça parfois, je crois que surtout quand c'est une maman, ça un peu voilà. Et donc ma mère m'envoie ça et donc je me dis waouh.
Et elle t'envoie ça dans quel but ?
T'as vu ? Mais elle sait pas. Maman désolée. Non, elle sait pas. Elle se dit : T'as vu, il y a quelqu'un qui a fait ça sur toi, ça se fait pas, c'est grave.
Bienveillante quoi. Ouais, je sais que...
Ouais, ce qui est bienveillant, c'est plutôt de protéger de ce genre d'images, mais
Mais quand t'as plus de cinquante ans, tu sais pas. Enfin, tu vois. Et puis elle, je crois, elle était un peu paniquée aussi.
Mh.
Et donc elle me soumet ça. Je regarde, je me dis ok, ça, c'est vraiment... enfin, je veux dire, je sais ce que c'est, le droit à la critique.
Je comprends des concepts de liberté d'expression, etc. Là, c'est m'attaquer sur le fait que je fais... pardon, je sais pas si c'est censuré...
Non, non.
Sur le fait que je fais pas de pipe ou des choses comme ça. T'es là, genre, je crois que ça n'a pas grand-chose à voir avec ma fonction parlementaire. Et donc...
Alors là, tu présentes ça comme une lecture très rationnelle du truc. Émotionnellement, quand tu vois ça ?
Franchement, ça m'a... enfin, ça m'a vraiment tuée. Je me suis dit...
Je pense que ça... on parlait de rappeler que les policiers sont humains.
Ah oui.
Je pense qu'on peut rappeler que c'est... bon, moi, je me suis pas pris ce genre de truc-là.
Ouais.
Mais la même personne m'a emmerdé. Et d'autres personnes parmi ses fans ont aussi fait des caricatures de ma face, etc.
C'est pas...
C'est pas très agréable.
On souhaite ça à personne.
Non, non. Et en fait, ce qui est horrible, c'est que, ben déjà, tu te rends compte que ça peut exister. Alors lui, il a fait un nombre limité de fois, etc.
Mais en fait, là... je sais pas expliquer. C'est un peu comme s'il y avait une barrière qui s'était ouverte de se dire : Ok, c'est possible.
J'ai eu un autre truc pas cool contre lequel j'ai jamais porté plainte, mais que je trouvais immonde. Il y a une personne qui m'a prise en photo dans la rue avec une de mes potes pendant le confinement pour dire que genre j'allais me promener.
Mais en plus, c'était ridicule. J'allais chercher du pain à ma voisine. Enfin bref, histoire... enfin, je veux dire, légalement, il y avait rien de grave.
Mais à mon insu, quelqu'un m'a pris en photo dans la rue. C'est arrivé une deuxième fois où une personne a dit : Je l'ai vue à l'aéroport de Zaventem, je crois que j'allais chercher une de mes copines, je sais même plus en vrai, et a tweeté ça.
Je me dis : Purée, en fait, je suis observée, tu vois.
La photo, c'est super creepy. Le fait de remarquer une célébrité dans un aéroport...
Ouais.
Célébrité, c'est...
Grave.
Bon, ça, ça me choque moins.
Ouais, moins ouais. Mais la photo par exemple...
Ouais, c'est creepy ouais.
Donc je marchais et je... enfin forcément sur la photo, tu vois bien que je suis pas en train de capter qu'on me prend en photo.
Donc je suis là genre ouais tu vois, probablement en train de dire des conneries.
Avec ta baguette.
Oui, mais je trouvais ça... enfin là aussi, tu vois, ça veut juste dire ok, c'est possible. En fait, il y a des personnes qui pour me nuire peuvent me prendre en photo dans la rue.
Mais alors du coup, quand tu sors et...
Oui, c'est ça.
Pardon, je vais le dire comme ça.
T'es jamais safe quoi.
Non et quand tu sors et que t'es un peu bourré et que tu vois, t'es en train de déconner, etc. Je sais pas, tu dis quoi et quelqu'un va me prendre en photo ?
Il y a une espèce de devoir d'exemplarité, de perfection, de jamais pécher, de jamais... qui t'est imposé à trois cent pour cent et qui en plus, dans le cas de ta sortie dans la rue, n'était pas pertinent enfin.
Non et en plus l'exemplarité, la perfection, nanana. Si on continue à dire qu'en effet, il faut être une sorte de surhomme pour faire de la politique, en fait, on va jamais avoir personne qui veuille y être quoi.
Et donc oui, enfin, je sais pas comme... ouais, parfois, je suis bourrée parce que c'est le soir et que je suis avec des potes.
Oui, parfois, je sais pas, je dis un truc et puis je dis : Ah ben non, en fait, je me suis trompée. Enfin, tu vois, il y a plein de
choses comme ça qu'on tolère pas de la part des élus et des élus qui sont trop dommage parce qu'en fait, ça ferait de meilleurs élus quoi.
Ok, donc là, on a parlé de deux, trois exemples. Donc les caricatures quand tu étais à la mer, la photo, le tweet de quand tu étais repérée dans un aéroport.
Ma question à la base, c'était plus du : Ok, donc tu as déposé plainte par rapport donc...
À une partie de...
Au premier épisode.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc sur les caricatures que ta mère t'a forwardées. Comment est-ce que ça s'est passé ?
Alors, j'ai pris énormément de temps à le faire parce que comme d'habitude, tu te dis : C'est pas si important.
Est-ce que vraiment ça vaut la peine de mobiliser la justice, etc. ? Et puis, en même temps, et c'est la discussion que j'ai eue avec la chouette policière pour le coup, qui m'a accueillie complètement par hasard.
Cool.
Ouais.
C'est pas l'expérience de beaucoup de femmes.
Ouais, je sais bien. Et là, j'avais une personne qui savait ce que c'était Twitter et les réseaux sociaux quoi. Donc j'étais vraiment hyper contente finalement.
Cool.
Et en fait, elle m'a dit... parce que je suis allée en mode je sais pas ce que je vais faire, mais juste, j'ai besoin de vider mon sac avec quelqu'un qui s'y connaît.
Alors elle m'a bien expliqué que c'est évidemment pas à la police de dire si tu peux ou pas porter plainte, si ça vaut la peine parce que c'est pas leur métier.
Mais elle dit par contre, réfléchissez à qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait à vous. Et ça, je crois que c'est un truc que, quel qu'en soit victime de quoi que ce soit, on doit réfléchir à ça en fait.
Est-ce qu'une ligne rouge a été franchie pour moi ? En fait, dans ce cas-là, oui. Et en fait, ça m'a fait quelque chose, ça a modifié mon comportement, ça a un impact sur moi.
Et ben donc du coup, moi, j'estime que j'ai été lésée et je dépose plainte. Et après, la justice fait son boulot, elle décide si c'est...
Si la plainte est légitime ou pas.
Voilà, bien sûr. Mais c'est pas...
Alors que mais... donc tu as écouté le dernier épisode de Septante Minutes Avec...
Ouais.
Sur le mensonge, y compris les accusations de viol où, apparemment, souvent, les policiers se permettent de juger si la plainte est recevable, si
s'ils doivent l'accepter enfin, alors que c'est pas du tout leur métier quoi.
Non et non. Et ça, il faut vraiment à chaque fois qu'on te le demande ou qu'on t'en parle ou que t'entends parler de ça, il faut redire : on a le droit, quoi qu'il nous soit arrivé, de déposer plainte.
Après, la justice fait son taf quoi.
Oui. Et donc toi, tu es tombée sur apparemment une policière d'exception...
Ouais.
Qui t'a expliqué tout ça, qui t'a...
Franchement.
Qui t'a trouvé légitime.
J'ai pas dû lui expliquer Twitter, j'étais contente.
Oui, c'est effectivement, je connais d'autres exemples qui n'ont pas eu ton expérience. Et donc ta plainte, comment est-ce qu'elle a évolué ?
Alors, elle est partie dans les limbes de la justice.
C'est ça, dans les tuyaux.
Voilà. Et puis, c'est très rigolo en fait. Au bout d'un moment, le parquet m'a écrit un courrier complètement énigmatique que j'ai pas compris-
Mh.
Parce que juste moi, je jargonne pas judiciaire, donc j'étais là, pour dire qu'en gros ma plainte, je l'avais publiée d'ailleurs sur Twitter, mais ma plainte,
j'ai peur de dire les mauvais mots, mais genre en gros, rejoignait une autre plainte et donc du coup, il y allait pas avoir de suite parce qu'il y avait déjà eu des suites pour l'autre.
C'est ça, il y avait redondance, il y avait-
Ouais.
Un duplicata quoi en gros. En gros, il y a déjà une plainte, c'est bon, on va virer la tienne, on va se focaliser sur l'autre quoi.
Mais sauf qu'entre-temps de la lecture d'une avocate, parce que du coup, je me suis dit, je vais quand même montrer ce document, l'avocate me dit : Ah, mais c'est pas forcément un classement sans suite.
Et donc du coup, elle de me demander : Bah tiens, est-ce que ça continue cette histoire-là ? Est-ce que ça se fait toujours, etc.
? Est-ce qu'il y a encore des contacts entre vous et cette personne ? Et je dis ben oui, je pense bien. Et je dis j'ai, voilà, j'ai collecté des trucs.
Mh.
Mais donc
ça veut dire que techniquement la personne a été auditionnée par la police et que le fait qu'on lui dise qu'en fait j'avais été lésée par
ce qu'il avait fait me concernant ne l'a pas découragé à continuer à interagir avec moi de manière hyper désagréable et hyper,
comment dire, récurrente avec moi ou à mon propos, parce que c'est pas toujours des interactions directes.
Et de me dire qu'à tout moment quand tu déposes plainte, tu peux rajouter des pièces au dossier. Et donc j'ai rajouté des pièces au dossier et je me suis dit bon ben, allez à Jacqu'taïse, on verra bien...
Ce que dit Myriam, c'est que cette partie-là de rajouter des pièces au dossier, collecter les pièces, etc. C'est, en tout cas dans son cas, c'est presque un métier à temps plein-
Ouais.
Parce que tu passes des heures à remonter des trucs horribles que les gens ont écrit sur toi, à les rechercher et tout ça...
Mais d'un côté, j'ai déposé la première plainte, donc ce serait dommage de laisser tomber.
Oui, puis c'est un beau rêve de le voir croupir, donc...
En vrai, je crois que... Enfin oui,
je crois que c'est aussi un luxe de pouvoir le faire.
Alors chez Écolo, on a une chance énorme, c'est que pour tout ce qui est cyberviolence, il y a un accompagnement et donc j'ai accès, si j'ai besoin, à une CM qui peut nettoyer mes DM pour pas que je
mange mon caca moi-même.
J'ai accès à un soutien psy si j'ai envie et j'ai accès à un avocat ou une avocate si j'en ai besoin.
Oui.
C'est la même chose si t'es une élue et que tu subis des agressions sexuelles par exemple, c'est la même chose.
C'est comme ça que je pense qu'on peut mieux protéger des mandataires et des élus et des élues pour après permettre à d'autres de s'engager en se disant pas : Oui, mais quoi,
si j'ai un collègue qui a un comportement inadéquat avec moi, je dois me vider mon compte en banque pour payer des frais de justice.
Non, c'est pas comme ça quoi.
Et c'est intéressant parce qu'en question, je trouve un peu de coupole, c'est
la responsabilité des partis sur toutes ces questions-là, je pense qu'elle est énorme
et que par exemple, mal protéger les élus qui subissent des violences quelles qu'elles soient, ben ça, c'est un critère de découragement en fait.
Et s'il y a plein de meufs qui ont pas envie de se lancer en politique, c'est aussi à cause de ça quoi. Ou au contraire...
Enfin, moi, j'ai découvert la sororité en politique, c'est un grand concept. Inexistant.
Voilà, ça Ah ouais, je suis flippé par ta réponse.
Ouais.
Ok. Mais attends, donc là, on digresse, on digresse, on digresse. On va revenir sur l'inexistence de la sororité en politique, qui pourrait être un titre de podcast, mais revenons sur cette plainte.
Donc a évolué, n'était apparemment pas classée sans suite. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Ben du coup, je sais pas très bien te donner le statut précis.
C'est là où on en est en fait.
Ouais, c'est là où on en est. Ouais, c'est qu'elle est toujours ouverte puisque je peux reverser des pièces au dossier, etc.
Je ne sais pas, en fait, c'est ça qui est très compliqué, c'est que t'as peu d'infos sur la procédure. Et donc par exemple, je ne sais pas si la personne va être réauditionnée ou j'imagine qu'elle va être prévenue quand même.
Enfin, je sais pas très bien. Et je l'ai dit, parce que du coup t'as le numéro du centre d'aide des victimes, donc tu peux appeler pour demander un peu où ça en est, etc.
Et la dame me dit ah oui, mais ça, c'est le parquet quoi. C'est comme si c'était une espèce de... Mais tu vois, donc il y a zéro transparence.
Oui, c'est limite encore plus que la politique, le monde judiciaire, c'est très complexe.
Tu feras un autre podcast là-dessus.
Oui, c'est. C'est, et surtout, c'est pas assez financé puisque ton truc, tu l'as introduit quand ta plainte ?
En 2020.
Ok. Donc ouais, donc ça fait deux ans et demi, un peu plus que c'est dans les tuyaux, que ça avance pas. Myriam, ça fait dix ans qu'elle traîne son-
Ouais.
Sa plainte.
Et je connais des personnes qui ont même porté plainte pour des cas complètement privés, hors de la sphère publique, je veux dire, et qui attendent encore aussi après des dizaines d'années. Donc en vrai...
C'est ça. Oui, ok. Donc ça, c'est pour ta plainte. Dernier commentaire au sujet de ce dossier-là. Tu en as parlé sur Twitter ?
Comment est-ce que ça a été reçu ?
Je fais attention à ce que j'en dis parce que déjà, j'ai toujours peur qu'on m'attaque pour diffamation parce que comme je disais, je suis une quille en droit, voilà.
Tu donnes pas le nom de la personne.
Non, non, non, jamais, jamais. Et j'ai pas envie, parce qu'aussi, j'ai pas envie de régler ça publiquement.
J'aimerais juste que la justice décide, quoi.
En tout cas, quand tu as reçu ce retour comme quoi la plainte était archivée, mais en fait non, enfin voilà, quand tu as reçu ce retour-là de la part de la police.
Ouais, là, j'étais un peu frustrée.
Voilà, t'en as pas-- Tu as montré ta frustration sur les réseaux.
Enfin, il y a un principe logique qui m'échappe.
Le plus étrange dans tout ça, c'est que la suite de l'histoire, c'est ah mais non, en fait-
Finalement, c'est ouvert.
Oui, c'est ça.
Donc-
Super bizarre.
Ouais, franchement.
Bref. Tu en parles sur Twitter ?
Fais un jour un sujet sur ça, sur le monde judiciaire. C'est hyper opaque.
Mais je pense que la réponse que j'aurai à toutes les questions, c'est on n'est pas assez financé. Ah oui, ça devrait aller plus vite, mais on n'est pas assez financé.
On devrait faire ça mieux, mais on n'est pas assez financé. Je pense que j'aurai cette réponse-là à toutes les questions.
Mais comment ça marche qu'ils reçoivent une plainte ? Je comprends même ça, tu vois, je...
Ok, oui.
Vraiment le... Je sais pas celui-là, tu vois.
Oui, oui, ok, non. Ok, suggestion intéressante. Mais donc revenons juste donc au fait que tu l'as tweeté. Quelle réaction est-ce que tu as eu face à la frustration que tu affichais vis-à-vis de cette plainte ?
Ben alors, c'est toujours la même chose, c'est que c'est un peu ce truc de ben oui, vous vous victimisez.
Mh.
Et donc ça, c'est-
Systématique, ouais.
Ah ouais, mais enfin franchement, donc tu souffres d'un truc parce que c'est ça tu vois. Et puis après on te dit ah ouais, mais t'as tort de souffrir quoi.
Et ce qui-
Plus de ça, tu en joues.
Je sais pas si tu as écouté l'épisode avec Alex Mahoudeau sur le wokisme et les anti-woke-
Pas encore.
Non ? Un des trucs qu'il disait, c'est que les anti-woke, justement, passaient leur temps à se victimiser et à dire que les wokes-
On ne peut plus rien dire.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Ben ouais, que la gauche est partout, a infiltré dans chaque organe de cet État.
Bref, donc tout le monde t'accuse de te victimiser parce que tu portes plainte pour cyberharcèlement.
Voilà.
Ce qui est étrange.
Et de, et de gros-, en gros considérer que c'est-- ça ensuite, parce qu'apparemment les personnes avaient toutes des diplômes en droit et ont bien compris le-
Mh.
La finalité du courrier.
Oui, la police a toujours raison, l'institution a toujours raison, tout est parfait.
Et puis enfin surtout, je veux dire, même mon avocate n'a-- a demandé des compléments d'information au parquet sur ce qui était écrit dans le courrier.
Mh.
Donc je pense pas qu'un gars de Twitter puisse l'interpréter-
Ouais, ok.
De manière, voilà, tu vois. Et donc j'étais un peu là genre mh-
T'as ça, des gens qui sont très biaisés contre toi, je pense.
Ouais.
Je pense.
Au fond, oui. Au fond, fine, tu vois, je veux dire, c'est toujours les mêmes gens qui... voilà.
Ok. Bon, mais en fait, je te posais la question parce qu'il me semble que des personnes du monde politique ont réagi aussi.
Oui, alors ça, c'est vrai, j'avais oublié.
Je suis là pour te rappeler.
Merci. C'est vrai que c'est un peu le mood actuel, c'est que des mandataires mettent leur petit like ou leur petit retweet sur des choses qui concernent parfois ben des cas qui sont pourtant en justice, etc.
Ouais.
Je veux dire, moi, voir des personnes qui accusent certaines personnes que je côtoie d'islamisme, etc. Et voir qu'il y a des présidents de parti ou des députés qui likent et qui retweetent.
Je suis là oh waouh ! Alors-
Ouais.
Mais enfin surtout, il faut imaginer, il y a beaucoup de gens jeunes qui se font cibler par ça. Alors beaucoup de femmes en général, mais aussi des personnes racisées qui subissent ça.
Moi, si à vingt-quatre ans, je commence à me faire avoir des tweets qui parlent de moi comme étant un islamiste qui sont likés par un président de parti, franchement, je pleure quoi.
Enfin, tu vois, c'est chaud quoi.
Ouais.
Et donc c'est vraiment compliqué, je trouve, parce que quand tu es un élu, donc on--
pardon, hein, mais on t'embête à te dire : Ah, tu peux pas prendre l'avion, tu dois trier tes déchets et faire tout de manière exemplaire.
Tu peux pas boire, surtout pas faire une vidéo où tu danses parce que ça, c'est vraiment la débauche.
Mais par contre, c'est OK d'aller liker des agresseurs, d'aller liker des propos racistes, je veux dire retweeter des gens de l'extrême droite française, enfin, c'est un truc...
Mh. Mais ça, c'est intéressant. Bon, on parle de Jean-Philippe Boucher, on va être clair.
Ouais, mais le problème, c'est qu'il est même pas seul à faire ça quoi.
Oui, en fait j'ai-
Ben dans ses mandataires, des gens vraiment conservateurs qui...
Oui...
Je sais pas si c'est par méconnaissance des outils. Parfois, je me dis peut-être, ils comprennent pas, tu vois. Et...
C'est ça. Peut-être, ils pensent que c'est privé.
Ils ont glissé.
C'est un DM.
Mais ça, moi, je trouve ça compliqué parce que pour le coup, autant je pense qu'il y a pas beaucoup d'exemplarité à avoir en politique au sens surhomme, tout ça, autant sur le fait de juste respecter.
Enfin, de la même manière que j'irais pas faire des excès de vitesse, je vais pas commencer à encourager des gens qui ont des propos racistes quoi, tu vois.
Donc enfin, tu vois.
Le-- ce qui m'a frappé dans ce que tu disais juste avant, c'est quand les gens t'accusent de te victimiser tout ça, ta réaction, c'est « oui, ça, à la limite, fine ». Pour te citer.
Tu retiens tout quoi.
Tu l'as dit il y a cinq secondes.
Ouais.
Ça va. Ça va. Mais effectivement, je retiens tout. Et donc concrètement, est-ce que tu t'es fait une carapace ? Est-ce que t'es insensibilisée à ce genre d'attaques super violentes ou-
Mh.
Ou pas ?
C'est trop drôle. Je peux raconter une anecdote, mais c'est hyper personnel. Je sais pas si tu verras si-
C'est absolument ce que tu veux.
Si tu la gardes. Je vois une psy comme beaucoup de personnes de-
Bien sûr, moi aussi.
De mon âge. Voilà. Et parce que je trouve que la santé mentale, c'est important. Et on a fait toute une séquence parce que j'ai perdu un membre de ma famille assez proche.
Ça a été assez difficile.
J'ai vécu aussi une rupture. Enfin bon, j'avais plein de trucs à gérer, mais c'est marrant parce que moi, dans ma liste des points que j'amenais, il y avait absolument pas de trucs liés au boulot, à mon mandat politique, etc.
C'est elle qui t'en a parlé ?
Et c'est elle qui m'en a parlé et qui m'a dit « Madame, à quel moment vous allez aborder le cyber- » Et j'étais là « Ah ouais, il y a ce petit truc-là ».
Mais elle me dit « Mais vous vous rendez compte que c'est important et que c'est violent en fait ». Et donc-
C'est quand même bizarre que ce soit la psy qui décide ce qui est important pour toi.
Non, oui, mais elle attire mon attention sur l'existence de ces faits-là, en mode mais pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas amené ici quoi ?
Elle m'interroge. Et en fait, je crois que j'ai, pour ma survie personnelle, opéré une distinction très forte entre le privé, donc un deuil, une rupture, tout ça et le travail, le professionnel, mon mandat.
Je pense que beaucoup de politiciens font ça. Je pense que beaucoup de gens, quand ils donnent des réponses à des interviews, réfléchissent à comment est-ce que je dois apparaître, comment ça.
Et finalement répondre par rapport à leurs sentiments profonds, etc. C'est quelque chose qu'ils ne calculent même plus. Ils répondent par rapport à-
À la, voilà.
Ce, la façon dont ils veulent apparaître, elle veut apparaître.
Mais c'est fou parce qu'en fait, rien n'est déconnecté, tu vois, je veux dire...
Oui, c'est artificiel.
Oui, et puis il y a des trucs de mon privé qui sont importants pour moi et qui du coup pèsent dans mon professionnel et inversement.
Et la raison pour laquelle, je sais pas moi, je suis mobilisée sur une question comme l'endométriose, c'est parce que j'ai dans mes proches des gens qui sont atteints.
La raison pour laquelle, ben justement, la question de santé mentale, je trouve ça important. C'est parce que aussi, j'ai des proches qui ont eu des graves dépressions et tout.
La raison pour laquelle tu as travaillé sur l'IT, c'est parce que tu-
Voilà. Ben oui, et donc, mais ça, c'est ça que je trouve ça dommage, c'est que parfois, à cause de tous ces codes, ce costume, ce rond en fait, dont je parlais au début,
ben tu perds aussi de la spécificité des gens qui se sentent obligés de rentrer dans le moule, du coup de se conformer.
Enfin, et du coup, c'est-
je trouve que c'est nul parce que ça perd en représentativité tout simplement. Et qu'au final, ton parlement,
si tu laisses faire les choses naturellement, hein, que tu enlèves les quotas, que tu enlèves toute l'énergie qu'on va essayer de diversifier les parlements, tu vas te retrouver avec des parlements où tout le monde se
ressemble, tout le monde a les mêmes dadas,
tout le monde a les mêmes préoccupations et euh-
'Fin, et tu vois, et des fois, c'est grave parce que,
'fin moi, ça me fait assez sourire, mais par exemple, pour interpeller dans le Parlement, etc.,
on utilise souvent les sorties presse quoi, tu vois.
Donc t'épluches la revue de presse le matin, tu vois un sujet : ah ça, je vais en parler dans le Parlement. Et je me suis déjà dit : c'est dommage de pas plus prendre le temps,
tu vois, de chercher des nouveaux thèmes, des choses qui n'ont pas été traitées par les médias, d'amener vraiment des nouvelles questions quoi.
Les médias sont un filtre et si les médias refusent de parler d'endométriose, on parlera pas d'endométriose.
Voilà, tu vois. Et donc moi, souvent, j'ai eu ce cas de me ramener au Parlement avec des sujets où les gens étaient là genre : oh waouh, ça sort d'où ce truc ?
Étaient là : ah bah si, parce qu'en fait-
Septante Minutes Avec.
Voilà. Mais du coup, c'est ça qui, ouais, qui moi m'a toujours-- Mais c'est-- Et je trouve ça-- 'fin, tu vois, en fait, si tu laisses faire les choses, parce qu'on dit toujours que : ah, laissez faire tout ça, ça ira bien.
En fait, si tu laisses faire les choses, ça stéréotype trop et le monde politique est tellement-- 'fin tous ces codes dont on parlait au début, mais tellement codifiés d'une certaine manière que, bah, le moule te rattrape quoi.
Ok. Mais donc là, t'as répondu très très loin de ma question, même si c'était très intéressant.
Ouais, pardon.
Je te parlais à la base de : est-ce que tu t'es fait une carapace ? Donc tu m'as parlé de ta psy.
Ouais, et du coup, ben c'est ça en fait, la carapace, c'est aussi se conformer en fait, tout simplement.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est une décorporalisation presque.
Ouais, un peu.
Tu oublies-- Ouais, c'est ça, ok.
Et un peu, tu te détaches de ce que t'es, qui t'es, machin, pour à certains moments avoir la paix en fait, un peu, tu vois.
Donc je vais reformuler ma question. Est-ce que t'as quitté cette démarche de-
Séparer la femme de l'artiste.
Oui, oui, ça.
De séparer la professionnelle de la Margaux de tous les jours.
Est-ce que t'as quitté cette démarche-là ou est-ce que tu le fais toujours ?
Euh, ben donc c'est un truc qui est venu. Donc au début, pas du tout et puis de plus en plus. Je pense que ça s'accentue par moment de stress, de machin.
Donc ça peut revenir, mais t'essayes de le minimiser.
Mais par contre, ce que je pense qui est très important, c'est à un moment donné de revenir aux fondamentaux. Par exemple, je pense que je suis-- et vraiment, je ne, je sais pas.
À chaque fois que je formule ça, j'ai envie de le jurer sur la tête de mes chats ou un truc comme ça pour que ça passe bien.
Mais je ne me projette pas à long terme en politique. Je suis pas en train de faire des calculs en train de me dire : ah, je vais emménager à tel endroit, comme ça, je vais être mise sur la liste de...
Vraiment, je m'en tape, je te le jure dans les yeux, je m'en tape. Et du coup, ça, c'est un bon truc de,
justement, de-- parce que je pense que si j'avais vraiment-- si j'allais trop loin dans le professionnel d'un côté, ben je commencerais à me dire : ah tiens, mais du coup, euh...
Oui, oui.
Moi, ça m'a toujours-- je juge pas les personnes qui le font parce que le système est ainsi fait, mais les personnes qui déménagent pour des raisons électorales, j'ai jamais compris quoi.
On va revenir après sur le futur de ta carrière politique et de comment tu perçois les choses. Mais donc juste pour revenir sur la séparation entre Margaux et l'artiste.
Ouais.
J'aime bien parce que moi, je digresse beaucoup, mais toi, tu-
T'es un peu-- tu fais ça aussi. Donc du coup, est-ce que tu-- ouais, en fait, t'as répondu, tu disais tu le fais-- tu essayes de plus trop le faire, mais parfois, ça peut revenir.
Mais pour ne pas justement me faire influencer dans ma vie privée par des trucs politiques quoi.
Voilà. Par exemple, quand tu te prends des insultes, des, euh... C'était quoi encore ? C'était, euh... Oui, tu te victimises, machin.
Ouais.
Là, ça revient.
Ouais, beaucoup plus fort. Et aussi dans des moments où t'es pas-- 'fin, par exemple, je fais une interview pendant les vacances, sur un sujet, sur-- je sais même plus ce que c'était le sujet.
Bah, c'était mon portrait dans l'Écho, un peu portrait, etc., mi-mandat, justement mon regard sur l'institution, tout ça.
Et à un moment donné, évidemment, le journaliste est venu sur les sujets, ce que j'appelle les sujets peau de banane quoi.
Je suis une écolo, donc on me demande quoi ? Le foulard, l'abattage rituel, la laïcité de l'État, tout ça, tout ça.
Donc j'ai répondu ce que je pensais être juste. Et puis évidemment, un passage où je dis une phrase qui est recoupée, malheureuse, machin, qui fait la une de Sept sur Sept,
et qui du coup me vaut un torrent de boue en plein milieu de l'été.
Là, par exemple, tu vois, j'étais pas prête. J'étais juste avant d'aller dans un voyage un peu pèlerinage avec ma maman suite au décès de mon père, etc.
Et j'avais pas du tout de barrières. Et donc là, j'ai pris toute-- 'fin, je crois que j'ai passé vingt-quatre heures dans mon lit, j'étais là : en fait, ça me donne un peu envie de,
de ne plus jamais parler à personne, c'est ça.
Mais donc ça dépend quoi. Il y a des fois où quand c'est dans le feu de l'action, etc., ça va. Et puis il y a des fois où ça te prend un peu comme ça.
Et il y a aussi des fois où, et là, c'est comment la politique a pu me changer, par rapport à cette carapace, ou des fois où je me dis qu'en fait,
la seule manière, et c'est vraiment dommage, la seule manière de peser dans le débat à certains moments, c'est de prendre les codes des dominants
pour être confrontante, pour être super trash, alors que c'est pas du tout dans ma nature quand tu me connais quoi. Allez, euh-
Tu l'as déjà fait pour interpeller George Lesbouche, il me semble.
Plein de fois.
Ouais.
Ouais. Et ça me ressort pas du tout. Donc c'est juste une manière de monter sur le ring de boxe parce qu'il veut faire ça sur un ring de boxe.
Tu veux faire quoi à un moment ? Mais-- pardon, je parle comme si je venais de marrer une belle cochette. Je me suis emballée. Non, mais tu vois-
Donc l'idée, c'est de pas te laisser faire et de réagir. Et c'est la seule façon dont la réaction pourra fonctionner.
Disons que j'essaie de changer les codes et de faire les choses différemment, d'être plus dans la concertation, travailler avec des collègues, même parfois de l'opposition, des gens avec qui je suis pas d'accord à la base, etc.
Mais sur certains cas où vraiment, je me dis : en fait, il faut que quelqu'un lui donne une autre vision du monde que ce qu'il est en train de donner, ben là, je suis obligée de reprendre les codes en place quoi. Tu vois ?
Ok. Donc tu montes sur le ring, mais euh...
Je sais pas si je suis très forte à ça en plus.
Oui, mais j'allais faire une analogie foireuse.
Mais en tout cas, c'est intéressant parce que ça veut dire qu'à certains moments,
tu te protèges avec ta carapace pour essayer de te protéger de toute une série de violences, mais à la fois, à certains moments, parce que les codes, tu sais pas tous les changer,
t'es obligé de t'exposer.
Et donc là, c'est-- après, tu te mets en boule et t'attends, tu te mets en position, euh-- Je mime en même temps pour ceux qui ne font qu'écouter.
Mais tu te mets en position de défense à-- comme à la boxe et tu te protèges quoi. Et c'est comme ça. Et c'est vraiment nul parce que j'aimerais même pas essayer de faire ça.
Oui. Euh...
De toute façon, je suis sympathie.
Je déteste ça aussi, la confrontation. À chaque fois, ça me met par terre. 'fin, c'est pas mon style.
Euh, revenons donc sur ta brillante future carrière politique qui va durer encore vingt ans. Est-ce que tu vas te représenter aux élections ?
J'ai pas encore décidé, euh.
Tu te mets une deadline pour ça ou euh ? Ou bien tu repousses toujours à plus tard. Est-ce que tu fais comme moi ?
Ouais, sûrement. Euh, ça dépend pas que de moi parce qu'il faut juste pour les personnes qui écoutent la formation des listes dans les partis, tout le monde a sa recette.
Certains, c'est des comités des sages. Chez nous, c'est les membres qui décident. Donc il faut quand même que les membres Écolo aient envie que je le fasse pour que je puisse juste prétendre à le faire.
Ce qui n'est pas sûr parce que, 'fin, a priori, j'ai pas sondé de gens, 'fin, il y a plein de gens talentueux, etc.
Tu pourrais leur poser la question.
Faut que je passe beaucoup de coups de fil et c'est un peu...
C'est un peu long.
Voilà. Pas très intéressant en tout cas. Ça, c'est la première chose. La deuxième chose, c'est que ça va dépendre de à quel point j'ai le sentiment d'avoir fait bouger les choses parce que ça demande beaucoup d'énergie.
Je crois que le fait que je parle de plus en plus fort durant l'interview montre qu'il y a de l'énergie qui se dégage.
Tu parlais fort dès le début.
Je mens. Donc ça demande quand même vachement d'énergie et à un moment donné, je crois que c'est bien aussi qu'il y ait des gens plus frais chez euh, tu vois.
Oh OK. Donc, tu te dis ça pourrait être une autre-
Une autre Margot ou une Mariam ou une Louisa, j'en sais rien, mais une autre meuf qui pourrait me-
OK.
Qui pourrait me remplacer. Moi, du moment qu'on continue à avoir des parlements où on voit qu'il y a un rajeunissement, où on voit qu'il y a de plus en plus de femmes, qu'il y a aussi, ce que je ne suis pas, mais des gens de la diversité, etc.
Je trouve que c'est intéressant quoi. Et qu'elle soit féministe. J'ai oublié de le dire, mais en fait, c'est peut-être le numéro un.
OK.
Je ne me laisserai remplacer que par une féministe.
OK, donc, tu n'es pas sûre et ça dépend-- finalement, tu évites de trop te poser la question en te disant : ''De toute façon, c'est pas moi qui choisis si je suis bien placée sur la liste ou pas.''
Ouais, je me réfléchis clairement derrière ça. Et aussi parce que je trouve ça important de garder en tête qu'on n'est pas irremplaçable.
Il y a des exemples de pays dans le monde où, par exemple, il y a des premières ministres qui partent en congé mat' assez longtemps et où en fait, c'est des équipes qui les remplacent.
Enfin, je veux dire, il faut arrêter ce mythe de l'homme politique ou de la femme politique, genre ouais.
Dans sa carrière, dans sa...
Ouais, et qui sait tout. Enfin, je veux dire, tu bosses jamais tout seul. Moi, les personnes avec qui je travaille, bon, c'est toutes des femmes, mais les collaboratrices que j'ai, d'office, elles peuvent prendre le relais sur mes dossiers.
Elles savent tout en vrai, hein. Elles ont juste pas le droit de monter à la tribune pour parler, mais. Et donc je crois que vraiment, il faut aussi travailler là-dessus.
C'est quelque chose que Écolo porte un peu dans son ADN, le renouvellement.
Oui.
Je peux ?
Vas-y, challenge. Je vois venir.
Bah oui, bah oui. Jean-Marc Nollet, pourquoi est-ce qu'il est toujours là ?
Ah, c'est pas ce que je pensais que t'allais dire. Parce qu'encore une fois, des membres ont décidé que c'était OK. Et donc c'est la même chose, on a une autre députée ici qui-
D'accord, OK.
Qui dans le groupe a accumulé une fois de trop, entre guillemets, mais parce que comme il y avait un gros renouveau dans le groupe et qu'on était quatorze nouveaux mandataires, quasiment, enfin douze, je crois.
Il fallait pas trop de renouveau. OK.
Mais donc non, je pensais que t'allais me coincer sur : ''Du coup, vous êtes un parti où les gens font jamais de voix.'' Parce que c'est vrai que comme on a ce truc de décumuler, etc.
Oui, ce que me disait Gilbert Hendelbur, c'est que limite, il voudrait faire les affiches non pas avec des têtes de personnalités politiques, mais avec des sujets genre
on fait une affiche sur la mobilité, on fait une affiche sur le climat et pas,
pas avec la tête de Margot.
Bah ouais, et en fait, en vrai, c'est un vrai problème parce que dans le système électoral actuel, tu votes pour des gens. Et donc euh...
Tu peux aussi voter pour des listes, mais c'est plus rare.
Ouais, mais c'est beaucoup plus rare quoi. Et toute la culture des partis, 'fin bon, j'ai pas
des oreilles dans tous les partis, mais je sais qu'une personne qui fait pas de voix, on va la mettre une fois en haut de la liste et puis 'fin dans les, disons dans les dix premiers et puis si elle fait pas de voix, ciao, bonsoir.
Et donc c'est pour ça...
C'est légitime en même temps.
Oui, et donc c'est pour ça que ça fait un lien avec une question qu'on a vite abordée, effleurée au tout début, mais de quelle est finalement la solidarité entre les élus jeunes, les élus femmes, etc.
C'est qu'en fait, il y a une telle culture concurrentielle à l'intérieur des partis.
On va en parler, oui.
Que waouh quoi, c'est un truc de fou parce qu'en fait ouais, tu...
Donc on va, ouais, on va revenir sur cette compétitivité, cette agressivité, cette absence de sororité dans un instant.
Donc on a parlé de la question de ton renouvellement politique. Tu étais avant community manager. Tu as évolué vers le statut de député.
À quel moment est-ce que ça t'a intéressée de te présenter ? Et pourquoi ?
La version honnête, c'est en ayant bu beaucoup de vin un vendredi soir, le jour de la deadline.
Je ne m'attendais pas à cette réponse.
Non ?
OK, vas-y.
Donc j'étais avec des copines de chez Écolo et la deadline, c'était vendredi minuit. Et elles m'ont dit : ''Allez, mais meuf, fais une petite candidature.
T'as une chouette expérience de start-up. T'es plutôt quelqu'un qui est à l'écoute des autres. T'es plutôt à l'aise dans les débats, genre en mode pour concilier les points de vue, etc.
C'est pour toi quoi.'' Et j'étais là : ''Ouais, mais moi, je suis...'' Alors il faut savoir que dans les partis, t'as le personnel politique qu'on voit pas, les backstage, et puis t'as les gens visibles, les élus, les mandataires, etc.
Moi, j'ai toujours été dans les coulisses en fait. Et donc du coup, personne, 'fin, c'est rare de s'attendre à ce qu'une personne passe-
Oui, et on y revient à ce qu'on disait au tout début, c'est-à-dire, on part du principe que les politiciens et les politiciennes évoluent sur un plan complètement différent de nous.
On ne peut pas les toucher, on ne peut pas les atteindre, ils sont différents.
Ils ont fait Sciences Po.
Ils sont pas faits du même carbone que nous voilà.
Voilà. Et donc je pense que moi, j'avais pas du tout ça dans mon schéma mental. Aussi parce qu'en termes d'éducation, moi, je suis la seule de ma famille à avoir fait l'uni.
'fin, c'est pas du tout-- je pense pas que j'ai eu un background très privilégié d'un point de vue socioéconomique. Du coup, carrière politique, tu te dis, c'est un truc de nantis.
Et du coup, bah j'ai vraiment décidé ça sur un coup de tête. Je me suis dit : ''Bah tu sais quoi, en vrai, écrire une page sur mon parcours, ça va me prendre pas longtemps.
Je vais l'envoyer, on verra bien.'' Et puis, je sais pas à quel point, bah si, je peux en parler en vrai. Après, tu passes devant un comité de liste qui est fait de représentants et de représentantes de toutes les composantes du parti.
Et puis après, tu passes devant l'assemblée générale quoi. Et alors, c'est très rigolo parce que pour l'anecdote, il y a plein de gens qui savaient pas du tout qui j'étais en fait, et dont des gens qui habitaient la même commune que moi.
Or, pour la politique, c'est très important l'ancrage local. Et du coup,
bah c'était un peu violent quand même, tu vois, parce qu'ils étaient là : ''Mais c'qui, machin.'' Et puis je ne sais pas si c'est ma présentation, ce que j'ai raconté ou peut-être aussi dans la formelle, parce que forcément,
c'est une assemblée générale, donc il y a tout le monde qui est là.
Finalement, ma candidature est passée avec celle des autres de la liste, mais donc il n'y a pas eu de focus sur moi en mode ''On ne veut pas celle-là''.
Et donc oui, c'était complètement... Franchement, je pense que ça a duré deux, trois mois en tout entre le vendredi soir avec du vin et le moment où vraiment, j'étais actée en étant sur la liste.
Et j'ai vraiment eu-- Je me suis dit : Punaise, en fait, en trois mois, ma vie a changé quoi, tu vois ?
Sur un coup de tête quoi.
Oui, sur un coup de tête. Tu vois, j'ai encore du stress à en parler. Ça m'a stressé de ouf. Je me suis dit : Qu'est-ce que tu as fait ?
T'étais relativement bien placée sur les listes bruxelloises, donc tu étais en seizième position.
Oui, place de combat qu'on appelle ça.
Ok, oui, ce n'est pas gagné d'avance, mais-
Non, mais en fait avec le-
C'était au moment où on parlait de la vague verte.
Oui, voilà. Et puis qu'avec, tu sais, il y en a toujours un ou deux qui part ministre ou secrétaire d'État. On a eu Rajae qui est devenue coprésidente, donc ça a fait monter quelques personnes.
Parce que oui, et ça, c'est une des critiques qu'on me dit tout le temps : Je suis non élue.
Est-ce que tu as été cooptée par-
C'est un truc de fou. Alors que par hasard, je la connais et par hasard, c'est une de mes potes de chez Écolo, des personnes avec qui je m'entends bien de chez Écolo.
Et donc du coup, on suppute que : ''Ah, mais c'était un calcul''. Franchement, si on était capable de faire des estimations et des trucs comme ça, on serait au summum.
Juste pour clarifier ce à quoi tu réponds, c'est une accusation récurrente de, tu l'as dit, de-
Député.
Tu n'as pas vraiment été élu, tu étais coopté, c'est... Bon alors que-
Ou suppléante, si on veut.
D'autres politiciens dans d'autres camps qui n'ont pas tout à fait, qui n'ont vraiment pas été élus pour le coup, mais qui sont devenus sénateurs cooptés.
Toi, ce n'est pas ton cas.
Non, non, non. J'ai eu un nombre de voix qui m'ont permis d'être élue.
C'est ça. Et je crois même-- Attends, est-ce que je dis une bêtise ? Les personnes qui étaient en dessous de toi dans la liste ont été élues ou pas ?
Non.
Voilà, donc tu es la dernière de la liste.
Voilà, c'est ça.
C'est ça. Donc ça, ça s'est joué à pas grand-chose.
Voilà. C'est pour ça, on dit une place de combat quoi.
C'est ça.
Où je sais que si Écolo se plante aux élections la fois prochaine et que je suis au même endroit, je serai pas élue, mais...
C'est ça. La sororité en politique. Quand tu interagis avec des politiciennes d'autres camps, par exemple PS, Défi, MR, etc.
Est-ce que tu perçois des interactions amicales, correctes, cordiales ? Est-ce que tu as l'impression qu'il y a une concurrence ?
Comment ça se passe ?
Alors, je vais peut-être distinguer deux-
La gauche et la droite.
Non, mais deux situations différentes. D'abord, le fait que, comme je l'ai dit, je suis présidente du groupe de travail sur l'égalité, la Commission égalité.
Donc, ça veut dire que c'est moi qui suis chargée de vraiment d'organiser les moments de rencontre de tous les députés, de tous les partis sur la question de l'égalité.
Et donc on est une quinzaine. Et quand j'ai ce rôle-là, c'est assez co-construit parce que c'est important et on l'a mis dans l'ADN de notre groupe de travail à la base.
On a envie de travailler tous ensemble, en fait. Il y a un homme, mais je mets quand même toutes. Pardon, j'ai dit ''fuck''.
Et donc, on a envie de travailler tous ensemble et d'être assez dans une démarche de co-construction, etc. Rigolo parce qu'on est la seule commission à fonctionner de cette manière-là, mais bref.
Et donc, par exemple, même si tu es une députée de l'opposition, tu peux très bien déposer un texte et on essaye de collaborer dessus.
Alors, ce n'est pas absolu, c'est-à-dire que ça arrive que ce ne soit pas le cas parce qu'il y a des jeux politiques qui moi me dépassent, mais voilà.
Et où du coup, parfois, on ne travaille pas ensemble, mais donc on essaye de le faire ou en tout cas, c'était la volonté.
Et donc là, ça se passe bien. En général, tout le monde contribue parce que c'est sous le feu des projecteurs quelque part, parce que les travaux sont publics.
Ok, oui. Donc là, tu parles vraiment dans un niveau de collaboration professionnelle. Voilà, c'est ça. Quand les caméras sont éteintes.
Par contre, je distingue en effet avec les coulisses un petit peu où je me suis rendu compte, là où moi, dans mes anciens
rôles dans la société, mes anciens jobs, mais tout ce dans quoi j'ai été investie, il y avait quand même toujours un peu de solidarité, de sororité, de soutien mutuel, etc.
Là où le monde politique, et je dis le monde politique au sens large, que ce soit les experts et expertes des partis, tout le monde, il y a vraiment un truc de le parti avant tout.
Et donc, quitte à mauvaise foi, quitte à violence, quitte à tu vois.
C'est comme si à un moment donné, tout le monde se retranche derrière son parti quoi, pour être du coup désagréable, pour faire des coups pas chouettes, pour chourrer un créneau média, pour
s'arranger alors que tu as travaillé à plusieurs sur un sujet, mais pour avoir un article de presse à ton nom ou ce genre de truc quoi.
Il y a plusieurs choses dans ce que tu as dit, mais sur ce dernier point en particulier, l'idée qu'on essaye de, même si on est plusieurs à signer un texte de plusieurs parties différentes, qu'on fait une mini coalition sur un sujet,
il y a des signatures qui sont là juste pour pouvoir apparaître sur la RTBF ou pouvoir en parler pour dire : Oui, j'ai signé un texte.
Oui, voilà.
En fait, tu as juste signé un texte, tu as juste mis ta signature.
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, et ça, des fois, je trouve ça... Bon, moi, j'ai eu un cas presque rigolo. J'ai un de mes textes parlementaires sur l'endométriose qui a été copié-collé par un groupe politique dans un autre parlement en Wallonie.
Ils ont pris mon texte, ils ont fait sélectionner tout, copier. Oui, je fais langage IT au fait.
Ça va hein, ça va.
Donc ils ont sélectionné tout mon texte, ils l'ont copié, ils l'ont collé dans un document, ils l'ont déposé en enlevant forcément ma signature et celle de mes collègues et en mettant les leurs quoi.
Moi, je comprends pas, c'est des règles...
Est-ce que tu as le droit de porter plainte pour plagiat ou est-ce que...
Franchement, je me suis posé la question, puis je me suis dit : Tu sais quoi, ça-
Ça passera mal.
Oui. Et puis voilà, au fond, je comprends. Mais tu vois, pour te dire à quel point cette concurrence, elle est waouh ! Sur un sujet endométriose, c'est un sujet féministe pour moi, tu vois ?
C'était signé par des meufs de l'autre côté.
Donc, c'est clair, c'était quel parti ?
Ils ont changé de nom récemment.
Les Engagés, ok. Et euh-
Mais je-- Les personnes sont-- Je pense que c'est pas-
Non, c'est parce que tu parlais de compétition en fait.
Oui.
Bon, c'est vrai qu'ils ont viré ton nom. Tu pourrais malgré tout être flattée ?
Ouais, je me dis que mon texte était bien.
Voilà, ouais. Je veux dire, quel est l'aspect compétitif là-dedans ?
Mais c'est d'être les premiers à déposer un sujet, un texte sur ce sujet-là dans ce parlement-là.
Pour pouvoir apparaître dans les médias, pour pouvoir prendre les projecteurs, etc.
J'imagine, ouais. Et ça, c'est très compliqué parce que moi, j'essaye en tout cas de toujours me redire : OK, sur tel sujet, il serait utile de faire évoluer les choses comme ça, un texte de loi ou quelque chose.
Est-ce que je vais y arriver tout de suite ? Je sais pas. Est-ce que je vais y arriver moi-même ? Pas toujours. Des fois, tu dois négocier, des fois, tu te retrouves avec :
Bah ouais, nous, on veut bien cosigner, mais seulement si on est primo-signataire, donc si on apparaît en premier.
Et au final, je me suis dit : En fait, à moi-même, tu n'es pas là pour longtemps. C'est pas marquer l'histoire ou avoir ton nom sur des trucs, c'est pas un truc qui est important pour moi.
Du coup, en fait, au final, tant pis du moment que ça avance et fine. Oui, OK, tu veux ton nom, tu veux ton interview.
Oui. Malgré tout, est-ce que t'as essayé de l'avoir au téléphone ? Lui demander what the fuck ?
Non, j'ai laissé faire ça à d'autres personnes parce que je-
Non, mais parce que tu pourrais te demander, tu pourrais te poser la question, mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc ?
Moi, l'explication, je pense que c'est une conseillère ou un conseiller qui a fait un excès de zèle.
Oui, ok, c'est peut-être pas la députée.
Ouais. Mais tu vois, par exemple, la même chose,
on a des conseillères
chez nous qui nous racontent qu'elles se font fortement interpeller sur les réseaux sociaux par des conseillères d'autres partis qui sont pourtant normalement hyper féministes, mais qui vont les dégommer juste pour
montrer qu'Écolo est vraiment nul sur tel sujet.
Et des fois, je suis là : Oh waouh !
Tu parles du PTB, là ?
Non, même pas forcément. On a eu le cas avec des filles, on a eu le cas avec le CDH encore. Enfin franchement, c'est assez-- Et j'imagine qu'on le fait, nous, quelque part.
J'en ai aucune idée moi. Je suis pas mentionné dans ces tweets-là, donc je sais pas. Mais ce que j'allais dire, c'est : il y a dans certains partis, mais donc tu as l'air de dire que c'est quand même assez...
Assez courant.
Assez courant, ouais, vraiment une culture du clash et du combat sur les réseaux sociaux.
Ouais.
Et c'est parfois assumé au niveau de la stratégie de certains partis de : il faut qu'on soit agressif sur les réseaux sociaux, il faut que nos militants tombent sur les militants des autres partis, tout ça.
Ouais, et moi, je trouve que c'est-- Alors, j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur, donc au-delà d'avoir été CM, j'ai aussi travaillé sur des questions de communication politique sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et franchement, c'est super trash de se rendre compte qu'en fait, les contenus les plus virulents, les plus offensifs sont ceux qui percolent le plus sur les plateformes pour des raisons algorithmiques que tu pourras développer dans un autre épisode.
Mais qu'en fait, par exemple, moi, à la base, quand j'allais former chez Écolo pour les réseaux sociaux, parce que je forme un peu les militants, les élus, etc.
On partait toujours d'un mantra, c'était espoir et solution quoi. Présenter de l'espoir et des solutions aux gens, arrêter de leur faire peur, arrêter de leur--
Mais en fait, c'est chiant parce que les codes des réseaux sociaux, ça fonctionne pas comme ça quoi.
Et donc si en sortant d'ici, je publie : Je suis pour la paix dans le monde, ben il va rien se passer. Alors que si je dis : Machin est un connard, ben là, ça va-
Il vaut mieux publier une vidéo au Parlement sous-titrée où tu craches sur les autres partis et où t'expliques que toi, t'es meilleur.
Ouais. Et ça, ça pollue aussi super fort le débat parce qu'en plus, la presse, et ça, c'est une boucle, tu vois, les médias, ils s'intéressent à quoi ?
Aussi à ce type de contenu un peu qui clashe, etc.
Faire du clic, ouais.
Et donc c'est tout le temps de l'alimenter. Enfin, tu vois, ça s'autoalimente vers un truc... Je sais pas aujourd'hui comment on peut-
Certains présidents de parti l'ont bien compris.
Voilà, exactement. Et ouais, et des gens, enfin des gens crédibles hein, enfin, je veux dire des gens qui ont un poids, comme on dit.
Et donc du coup, je sais pas comment on sort de là quoi. À un moment donné, c'est une énigme, même intellectuellement, tu vois, je sais pas.
Oui, oui. Autre chose à rajouter au niveau de l'absence de sororité ? Est-ce que tu as été déçue par le comportement de certaines où tu te serais attendue à du soutien et en fait, non ?
Ben oui, je pense que du coup, comme je pense que je suis à côté de la plaque en termes de codes, je m'étais là genre : ''Eh, mais on est copines !
'' Et puis en fait, ben non, pas trop, en fait, non.
OK, donc t'as voulu aller boire un verre avec d'autres députées ?
Avec des gens et puis j'ai compris que-
Elles t'ont mis un vent, elles sont pas venues ?
Non, mais j'ai compris de fil en aiguille qu'en fait, c'était pas... Et c'est bizarre.
Pas possible quoi.
Mais c'est trop bizarre parce que-
Dommage, ouais.
Ben oui, parce qu'en général, t'as quand même, 'fin, je veux dire, je n'irai pas boire des verres avec des gens du Vlaams Belang et la NVA, mais il y a une série de gens avec qui on a quand même un stock de valeurs assez partagées quoi.
Des gens avec qui vous faites des coalitions, par exemple.
Voilà, par exemple. Et même, même des fois dans l'opposition, des gens chouettes quoi, tu vois, qui ont des bonnes idées et...
Mais du coup, moi, je pense que ça participe aussi un peu de la toxicité du monde politique, si on peut le dire de manière aussi trash.
Oui.
C'est ça quoi. C'est que ben en fait-
On porte un maillot et on reste entre nous et on...
En même temps, c'est un système de représentation qui a été inventé il y a je sais pas combien de-
Millénaires.
De millénaires, 'fin ou au moins de centenaires, et qui se base surtout sur la notoriété des gens. Mais alors du coup, la notoriété, 'fin moi, je pense pas que ça apporte...
Par exemple, au niveau local, on essaie des trucs. Alors bon, c'est toujours les gadgets des écolos et donc c'est très vite
caricaturé, mais des trucs genre des élections sans candidat, tu vois, où c'est, t'as ton groupe local qui va décider qui va être échevin ou qui va être échevine
parmi un pool de militants et de militantes qui sont assez engagés.
Et du coup, c'est un consensus. Mais alors du coup, ça pousse parfois des personnes qui sont pas du tout, qui ont pas assez confiance en elles pour candidater à être désignées.
Et à la fois, ben ça te permet, ouais, d'avoir un truc qui fait assez consensus et... Mais bon, ça implique qu'on regarde moins le nombre de voix que font les gens et plus leurs idées, leurs motivations.
Ouais, c'est vrai. Ok, ok. Ok. On arrive au bout de septante minutes. J'ai-
Déjà ?
J'ai l'impression qu'on a commencé-- Mais oui, j'ai l'impression qu'on a commencé il y a dix minutes.
Et en plus, il fait toujours clair.
Ouais. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres points que tu aimerais aborder avant qu'on se quitte ou est-ce qu'on a un peu tout dit ?
Peut-être dire que c'est pas un truc, c'est-- Ben, ça va être trop bisounours. Tu vas me demander d'autres trucs après, je crois.
Je t'en prie.
Mais peut-être de dire qu'on gagnerait à
réformer super fort et radicalement nos institutions. Il y a une super analyse qui est faite dans un,
un de tes concurrents, une de tes concurrentes au podcast, qui fait la différence entre une réunion féministe et une réunion de parlement et qui-
La poudre, euh, Laure Bastide ?
Non, c'est l'homme politique, moi, j'en fais du compost. Elle a été invitée dans Cœur sur la table, je pense.
OK.
Et elle parle de ça, mais bref. Et c'est fou parce que-
On n'est pas concurrents, on est tous amis.
C'est vrai. Mais c'est fou de se dire que, en fait, si tu compares une réunion féministe avec un débat de Parlement, c'est des codes qui sont opposés quoi.
Je veux dire, dans une réunion de Parlement, tout le monde est obligé de prendre la parole tour à tour puisque tous les partis doivent s'exprimer.
Il y a un temps à parti qu'en général, on remplit. On a tendance à commencer toutes les interventions par : je ne vais pas être long et répéter ce que les autres ont dit, mais en fait, on ne fait que ça.
Alors qu'une réunion féministe, on parle beaucoup moins,
c'est focus, machin, machin. Et donc je pense qu'il y a vraiment de quoi changer, mais vraiment repenser complètement la manière qu'ont les institutions parlementaires de fonctionner
et que c'est le seul moyen pour arriver à faire émerger des nouvelles personnes dans le paysage politique.
Des nouvelles personnes, j'entends beaucoup de nouvelles personnes qui vont se renouveler, qui vont changer, etc. Parce que je crois que sinon, ben, des gens comme moi, on va pas rester quoi.
On va se casser, on va se dire : mais en fait, quel monde de fou quoi.
Est-ce que t'as envie de te casser et de dire quel monde de fou ?
Ben parfois, ouais.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais. Mais-
Mais on en a parlé.
Ouais, mais parce que c'est pas, parce que tu te dis à un moment donné-
OK.
Est-ce que ça change vraiment, tu vois ?
Bon, je sais pas si je vais dire que c'est bisounours parce que je pense que t'as bien expliqué les trucs qui allaient pas dans la façon dont l'institution du Parlement était structurée, codifiée.
Par contre, c'est sans doute un peu utopique, sans doute peu probable que ça arrive. D'autres choses ?
Je réfléchis un petit peu, mais...
OK. Est-ce que t'es contente de cet entretien ? Est-ce que t'as pu dire ce que tu voulais dire ? Est-ce que t'as pu vider ton sac ?
Ouais, j'ai dit plein de trucs. Comme d'habitude, je suis en train de me-- donc là, je te parle, il y a le reste de mon cerveau qui analyse tout ce que j'ai dit pour vérifier que je n'ai pas dit une connerie.
Donc, voilà, mais c'est normal. Donc, tu vois l'autocensure, le fait de réfléchir à : tiens, est-ce qu'on va isoler un morceau pour me nuire ?
Et ben, c'est là en background.
J'appellerais ça la prudence, mais ouais. Margaux, merci beaucoup.
T'as d'autres questions ?
Est-ce que-- ben en vrai, si tu veux qu'on continue à parler, on peut.
Ça va.
Mais, mais-
Je commence à dire des bêtises. Et toi, t'es content ?
Moi, je suis content, ouais. Mais en vrai, en fait, quand je démarre une interview et que c'est vraiment : oh, j'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec machin truc.
Et alors, tu travailles à tel endroit et machin. Et puis, qu'est-ce qui t'a amené à devenir députée ?
'Fin, et que c'est très structuré, machin, comme ça, c'est beaucoup plus... C'est pas artificiel, mais-
C'est plus le rond que le carré quoi.
On va dire ça, oui. On va dire ça.
Franchement, tu peux appeler l'épisode un rond dans un carré hein.
Et alors qu'ici, j'ai démarré l'enregistrement sans te le dire et très spontanément, je fais : OK, tu veux parler de quoi ? Et puis-
C'est marrant parce que par exemple, tu m'as pas demandé de me présenter. C'est la première fois que j'enregistre un truc où je dois pas dire qui je suis.
C'est aussi parce que comme tu sais, j'enregistre une intro avant de faire l'intro. Donc, en fait, je gagne un peu de temps.
Voilà. Margaux, tu es députée.
Quel est mon parcours ?
Pour ceux qui n'ont rien suivi, Margaux est députée. Et mais en plus, je t'ai présentée un peu en douce en-
Tu rigoles
...en parlant des autres trucs. Non, donc ouais, donc oui, je suis content. Mais surtout, et 'fin, c'est là que tu vois que moi, je fais attention aux trucs dont on se fout complètement.
C'est-à-dire la qualité du son. Si le son est pourri, je serai pas content. Si le son est magnifique, je dirais : ah, c'est le meilleur épisode.
C'est vrai ?
Mais je suis biaisé sur les trucs dont-
Non, mais c'est pas grave.
Parce que tout ça est très technique hein.
Donc, si le son est bon, si comme je l'ai dit, le mood est très organique, smooth et qu'on se parle pas de manière trop,
trop codée et que l'invitée est pas trop chiante et que les sujets abordés sont cool, franchement, c'est un bon mix. Je suis-
OK.
Je suis plutôt content du résultat.
Ça va.
Tu pourras pas revenir, par contre.
Non, c'est la dernière fois.
Voilà, c'est ça. Non, mais-
C'est la dernière fois.
Il n'y a qu'une seule personne qui peut revenir, c'est Myriam.
Ah ! Moi, je comprends. Moi aussi, j'aurais cette règle-là, je crois.
Margaux, merci beaucoup.
De rien, merci à toi.
Et à très bientôt.
Tout ça. Ciao.
Septante Minutes Avec est disponible sur toutes les plateformes de podcast. Si c'est la première fois que vous écoutez, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur votre plateforme préférée et à suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur les réseaux.
N'hésitez pas non plus à remonter dans les archives. Peut-être que vous serez intéressé par mes interviews de Florence Hainaut, Myriam Leroy, de Marie Pelletier, de Alice Coffin, de Rokhaya Diallo.
Je cible un petit peu, je parle plutôt des gens de gauche. Il y a aussi des gens de droite, mais bref, plein de super épisodes à trouver dans les archives.
Le site web de Septante Minutes Avec n'est toujours pas rénové. Ça arrive dans les semaines qui viennent. Et dans les semaines qui viennent, je vais interviewer d'ici peu,
Laurence Minner, qui est chercheuse, qui travaille sur les stratégies médiatiques des extrémistes, donc principalement les djihadistes, l'État islamique, de Al-Qaïda, etc.
Mais pas seulement, l'ultra-droite aussi. Ce sera dans deux semaines et, ne ratez pas ça. À très bientôt. Salut !